who you got in a lotto Nicki battle
oh Nikki yeah I gotta ask because I mean
I love life it's about to get stirred up
that's like I feel like it's getting but
that's also where if you ask me Kim or
Nikki I'm gonna go Kim
really she didn't write her [__] Yeah
well yeah
what are you talking about what I'm just
saying she's still only reason I say I'm
talking about the hierarchy Queen
Nikki's I think Nikki's the female goat
she is I think first of all that's not
disrespect me Nikki Nikki is a goat
whether whatever her gender no no for
sure she is one of the coldest artists
in the last decade 100 like we can't
sleep on the like her skill her pin
sonically she changed the goats on there
on records like exactly when she came
with that monster yeah that was her
record yeah and she that was whole Kanye
Ross like she is whatever gender aside
sex aside she is she's that [__] dope
she's that only person in that that she
could to me that has the same level of
talent and that you should even we
should even be comparing her to is
Lauren I was gonna say Lauren
I agree Missy to me probably out of out
of the three we just named has my
favorite music
I just think that like when I'm over
Lauren well I mean Lauren only has one
album Missy got more well there was the
score and then the miseducation but I
just feel like Missy had like a four or
five hour run that was just like Jesus
Christ but those those are the three she
was working with Timberland yeah dope
Missy helping write for [__] genuine
and oh everybody Aaliyah everybody SWV
Missy's Missy's
but so Missy Nikki as well as Lauren
who's your overall top five all time and
no order I don't make you put that's so
difficult I mean we do this on my show
all the time we break it down in
categories that's what I was talking
like storytelling but if we're just
saying overall overall
is it like this is the most influential
person in hip-hop to ever do it okay um
then Hove the best to ever do it to from
the authenticity I agree just that
sounds like like I said we went from
influence uh then we went to uh then it
gets tricky because there's so many
other people that could check this box
right but I need like like more the the
effect on the culture with your lyricism
ah
that's when you got to give it to the
ogs so that's where you got to go into
space is like the the the the rakims the
ll's the ice cubes like that's I I if I
they're equal to me but if I'm gonna
have to go most successful I'm gonna go
Cube oh so you gotta say Cube yeah yeah
so cute so I go Cube S3 uh and then
[__] that's where we get to that sticky
Point uh well you already said Eminem's
top five but that's what I'm saying well
I'm saying because I'm still I'm gonna
give you my last three and this is six
okay so
it has to be between
Kendrick Drake and M I love that you put
Kendrick in there it has to I agree with
you man yeah like it got so but I don't
know where those three go that's fair I
like can like Drake might cancel out
right him and put him at six Kendrick
might cancel out Drake and put him at
like I don't know where those last three
go like well really because there's only
two spots left and I got three people I
love the it's a good six yeah yeah so
it's a respectable six yeah yeah only
person missing is Nas in my opinion
cube out
I would what cube is done for the
culture uh
the at that level though okay what about
this there's this debate
50 Cent versus Lil Wayne in a versus
Battle who wins all day I agree because
this Wayne got more records yeah 50 has
the biggest song in hip-hop history
let's not get in the club in the club is
the biggest song it's either that or
Usher yeah which is not necessarily hip
hop
the two biggest songs in hip-hop history
are Rappers Delight in the club yeah my
kids know both of those for sure you
know what I mean like and it's just like
that I feel like 20 years from now we'll
be saying the same thing the two biggest
songs if uh are rappers are Lighting in
the club because that's just they're
bigger than they're damn near bigger
than hip-hop